[Musique]
il ne manquait que du verre dans le
cadre de la saintpatrique où l'on
célèbre la culture celtique l'espace
céser de la verrière a proposé un
atelier de danse irlandaise un moyen de
découvrir de nouvelles chorégraphies
j'aime bien la danse tu aimes bien les
danses en général et j'avais envie
d'apprendre et c'était l'occasion on a
globalement abandonné dans notre culture
tout ce qui
était danse populaire même musique
populaire on entend plus rien de de
musique folklorique et autres et là ça
fait du bien de revenir au racines en
fait si elle reste festive la danse
irlandaise requierre tout de même
certaines exigences c'est structuré mais
pas énormément et donc ça laisse
beaucoup de place à un peu d'imagination
et de disons d'improvisation personnelle
une danse complète faut compter entre 20
et 25 minutes et on s'arrête une minute
donc faut c'est quand même assez sportif
après cette initiation les participants
sont invité à danser lors du concert
celtique du groupe Boldair ce vendredi
au scarabé à La
Verrière les fillesain droiteain gauche
au garç
tour